this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode we're back to call of duty
to show jonathan the weapons from
warzone and oh boy it got him mad this
is kind of depressing guys because this
is one of my favorite historic weapons i
wrote two chapters of my book about it
and it also looked like this
not like that
make sure to check out the previous card
episodes including our vanguard double
bill of the multiplayer and campaign
weapons and if you enjoy this kind of
content make sure to keep an eye out for
our upcoming series loadout a show where
we take a look at the history and impact
of some of the most iconic weapons in
gaming from the m1 garand and the desert
eagle through to the minigun and the
ak-47
naturally jonathan will be making a fair
few appearances over on that show too so
make sure to check that out
right let's take a look at call of duty
warzone
one of my favorite firearms of all time
the mp5 now the k
cuts the short version that
has come over from black ops i think has
got a weird forend on it panguard
here's a k
the the k in its super compact form with
no kind of butt and nothing on the top
to get snagged and this one happens to
be gold plated which makes it look quite
video gamey which is why i picked it to
show you today for some reason the black
ops version has just it has a version of
a civilian
modern day
handguard because due to a quirk of u.s
law without jumping through some hoops
and paying some money you can't have a
foregrip on a semi-automatic pistol
version of this so someone came up with
a version that is just straight and has
cooling holes drilled in it so it's not
a right not the right fit for black ops
cold war warzone anything goes so fine
[Applause]
a little bit of a weird one here i think
this is meant to be a sig 552 commando
now it's clearly customizable to the nth
degree to the point where it can be a
rifle carbine whatever you want but it's
more angular
than
the sig 550 series it doesn't quite look
right it looks like one of these
weird call of duty i i have said legally
different but i don't think it's a legal
thing at all i think it's just a guess
it's a creative license thing but it
doesn't look as it should
right a bit of extra pressure to
analyze this one as it's one of the guns
that featured in my my book on british
bullpup firearms this is sort of the
l86a1 this thing basically an assault
rifle on steroids never really found its
niche it was supposed to be a squad
support
weapon light machine gun and in service
not not enough firepower to be a useful
light machine gun and too heavy and
awkward to be a rifle now how does this
thing look well it's pretty different in
detail so it has the overall aesthetics
of of the sa-80 every little detail is
wrong so the magazine release on this
when we see it actually operated is a
button like a small button well
infamously the magazine release on the
sc80 is a lever and in its original form
unprotected so if you accidentally
pressed it against you
out drops your magazine and that
happened to a number of
soldiers so that's that's not right the
hand grip is not right it's similar but
extended and some for some reason it has
picatinny rail on top of it which the a1
didn't have didn't have any picatinny
rail on it certainly didn't have a
continuous rail across the top we only
managed that with the a3 so and there
isn't an a3 lsw because it was got rid
of the barrel at least in this
configuration is not long enough it's
the wrong profile the flash hide is the
wrong one but maybe it's been modified
the outrigger as it's known this girder
thing here is too short
on the one in the game the bipod is
wrong a lot of it is wrong
now this is an interesting one
an interesting gun to include in the
game and
a very interesting gun in its own right
now you'd have been struck if you've
seen it in the game or if this is your
first time seeing it by how much this
thing looks like a baby mg42 and i think
they've done a good job of this one some
really odd design decisions on some of
these guns but this one is really quite
a nice reproduction of the real thing
i'm not sure what the customization
options are going to be for this but i'm
guessing they work around it somehow and
of course being a belt fed like machine
gun it has the lifting top cover feed
tray all the stuff you'd expect to see
and when we see that flipped up in the
game we've got
all the right bits inside as well so
good job on this one guys
yeah i'm not really a fan of this one on
the one hand it's cool that someone has
attempted to design a fictional cold war
era submachine gun on the other it's
kind of frustrating because there are so
many actual designs out there that they
could have just used i don't really see
why they bothered you know there are
styling cues of modern b t sub machine
guns the trigger guard area is
reminiscent of the hk smg2 prototype
thing there are all sorts of bits that
we could pull apart and say well this
looks a bit like this um
ump ish as well sort of and there are
burst fire sub machine guns of course
famously the mp5 navy trigger pack has a
three round burst feature on it but it
also has full auto the whole ethos of a
submachine gun is automatic fire yes
sometimes bursts can be can be useful uh
two round bursts on the chris vector
what seems to work really well my
limited experience with it but generally
speaking you want controllable because
it's a pistol cartridge and you want
automatic fire or the ability to get to
fire semi and just watching this game
play just reinforces for me that you are
kind of nerfing the design by including
that feature
and it just turns it into a sort of
generic
gun but it's it's a cool design don't
get me wrong the fact that they've got
the aesthetic right for the 1980s 90s is
is nice to see but i always prefer to
see real things
right i've been hit with a gag gun again
this is some sort of horrific gold skin
i'm not even sure what it's supposed to
be i think that's the accuracy
international ax 50. the short
suppressor on the end looks to be some
sort of option you do get suppressors
for 50 caliber rifles not sure that
there's one in service with the aw or
ax50 anywhere but um one that's that
short i'm not sure would be uh
particularly worth having on the gun
oh god it's got a charm on it as well
it's got a some sort of
anime puppy hanging off the left side of
it and now that i see the skin from an
angle
it's
kind of a damascus finish makes even
less sense than some of the brightly
coloured skins we see on guns because
these days you can send your gun off to
someone to dip it in cerakote or
something and it'll come out with you
know skulls on it or something so these
outlandish finishes on guns are not that
outlandish if people were insane enough
to use them in actual combat but this
one where it has some sort of bump
mapping effect or something where it has
relief to it and the fact that they've
done it to the scope as well
it ain't right
it's another deagle for once i haven't
got one out to to um wave about this is
a little
odd i don't think this matches any
actual model of desert eagle out there
it looks like the modern lightweight
shortened form but it doesn't have the
ports in the barrel or the picatinny
top rail i think it's just a kind of
another one of these tweaked designs i
don't know why they get tweaked in cod
games but anyway but for me as a in-game
design this loses something of the
presence of the desert eagle um by not
being
long enough
i will say and this is this is perfectly
plausible if if somebody is sufficiently
experienced and has strong arms and
wrists and you can fire it as an eagle
and have it look like it does on the
screen in terms of recoil someone like
me fires it it's going to pivot sharply
to the toward the ceiling because the 50
ae version of the desert eagle has a
significant amount of recoil and it does
take some strength and some practice to
master that the recoil is kind of
accommodated in the game by it has seems
to have a sort of maximum rate of fire
and you kind of can't outpace
you can't fire it faster as fast as you
can a lower caliber gun in the game
because otherwise you would just use
nothing but this the only the only
advantage to something like a glock
would be three times the round twice
three times around
another fictional fictional gun i don't
really know what this is supposed to be
interestingly it looks like a weaver
rail on top rather than a picatinny rail
which would fit with the cold war origin
better than the kitteny rail the
picatinny rail or the what is now a nato
standard rail didn't really become
popular until the end of the 90s
cold war's over so we'd expect no rail
or a weaver pattern rail on guns of that
era the gun itself is quite a cool
design i don't like the thumbhole stock
and there's no way you design a
submachine gun with a thumb hole stock
they're just too awkward you have to
kind of make
an effort to grasp the pistol grip
rather than just having it there and it
makes it excessively bulky i can't work
out what it's supposed to be made of so
the thumb hole stock would imply polymer
it doesn't look like polymer and in the
the actual cold war era is a bit early
for for that well other than things like
the stair eugene yeah i'm a little bit
nonplussed by it put it that way
someone's had fun designing it and
that's the main thing
oh
good
lord i may need to take a moment on this
one tremendously conflicted because on
the one hand i've been wanting to see
someone put an em2 in a game
other than that fallout 4 mod that
someone made which looks a lot better
than this so let me get one this
is
an automatic rifle em2 experimental
model two and hopefully you can see why
i'm face palming because broadly this is
correct so like if you if i showed it to
you and close your eyes you might think
oh yeah that's all right but then it's
it's been dropped on its carrying handle
from a great height and that and is
weirdly deformed for
no good reason the pistol grip which
should be this uh carved wooden
thing is wood but then it has extra wood
coming back here that doesn't exist on
any of the real guns and we have most of
them here at the royal armories it has a
checkering that was that never existed
on on the em-2
little details like the trigger guard is
quite sharply angled which is more like
the one on the later versions of this
the 762 nato versions where we brits
gave up on this short lower power
cartridge and went with the american
choice of 762 nato which is the first
thing that killed this experimental
design by the way the forend the
handguard is too short it's been cut off
too soon there's a really bizarre
birdcage flash hider that never existed
for this rifle so this is kind of
depressing guys because this is one of
my favorite historic weapons i wrote two
chapters of my book about it and it also
looked like this
not like that
pause okay nice touch you've clawed back
some points there guys so what we see
there is magazine off and then
if it had rounds in magazine on and that
would send the bolt home so it locks
open on the empty magazine and then when
you fit the fresh magazine the bolt goes
home speeds up the reload on this thing
now it's slowed down by it being a
ballpark but you claw back some speed by
it chambering its own first round in the
mag when you put the mag on cool idea
for the time
really hasn't caught on no one else has
done it it probably would have been a
problem but they have clearly been
watching some videos of this thing
shooting and that is functionality that
is on the em-2
well yuck sorry whoever designed this
i'm sure you put a lot of hours into it
it's cool it would be a cool sci-fi
design or like an alternate alternative
history 1980s design i can't get
alongside it as a
weapon that's supposed to supposed to
exist in our reality put it that way
looks like i'm squinting at a g11 now
the magazine on that sat above the
barrel and reciprocated in order to feed
the bizarre clockwork design and i'm
seeing some design cues toward the rear
that suggest that that that's still
that's taken from the g11 but now we
have it fed from a magazine at the rear
which is much more conventional so you
could i suppose argue this is this is
what the g11 might have evolved into in
the parallel universe it's not it's not
a bad design don't get me wrong it it
has that chunky
1990s aesthetic i would say looks
plausibly like it could function it's
just i think for me it's just too
distractingly like a g11 why not just
have the g11 in the game
this one's a bit left field i don't
think i knew this was in the game it's
the
swiss k-31 or a really short but maybe
the carbine version of it i always think
the cocking handle looks like uh two
rolos for those of you in the uk stuck
to the top and bottom of it that's just
the way my brain works and we have that
uh kind of ring pull cocking piece which
makes a lot of sense to me if you get if
you get a dud cartridge and you want to
re-cock and try again easy enough to
recock and also very positive
safety-wise for letting it down if you
have to de-cock the thing for whatever
reason anyway going off piste there
sounds great i have to say the
real sort of resonant report from this
thing which i'd expect from a full power
cartridge like this but um a little bit
wacky in a modern shooter
of course this is modifiable as
everything is and we've we've removed
the fixed carry the iconic
carry handle with the low power optic um
and replaced it with a sort of period
correct for black ops cold war a bit of
weaver rail which looks sort of bodged
on but you know why not and then an
optic attached to that and some sort of
change to the muzzle device i think in
the real world there aren't there aren't
too many options for an aug or auga1 but
this is old school with some relatively
subdued tweaks to it so i i quite like
what i see of it considering war zones
are basically a free-for-all of
modification and craziness this well
this one looks quite good
join us again next time uh in the
meantime you might want to check out the
royal armouries youtube channel and the
links in the description um the various
things that we get up to you might even
want to send us a small donation if you
would like thanks a lot guys i'll see
you again next week
[Music]
you